Dear Edward
is this story that is
born out of
this tragic circumstance.
I got you. Come here.
You’re gonna be okay.
There’s a deadly plane crash
and the only survivor
is a 12 year-old child
named Edward
who is my character’s nephew.
What happened
isn’t fair, Edward.
I know I will never
replace your mom.
Lacey’s wanted to have a child.
It’s been a struggle that’s
affected her marriage, her
self-esteem, everything.
And then suddenly
out of this tragic event,
there’s a boy who
drops into her lap.
And then her life
starts to change and
all this really
beautiful stuff happens.
The airline will
pay for a psychologist.
I think it could
be a good idea.
There’s this
grief group community
that comes from other people
who have experienced this loss.
Did you say a 12 year-old
boy named Edward?
Is it “the” Edward?
Are you the aunt?
Yeah. Yeah, that’s me.
I guess I’m the aunt.
How’s he doing?
How’re you doing?
(Inhale)
As disparate as
the experiences are,
this point of grief
connects lives
that would never
have known each other.
Dee Dee is someone who
thinks that she's got it all.
Hi.
With the death of her husband,
gradually discovers,
none of it is real.
He thought that he was gonna
turn things around financially
for you guys. I-
I know he was working on that.
Because the inciting incident of
the show is so tragic,
people might think that it’s
gonna be depressing.
But really, it is about
watching people
be resilient.
They find love,
they find connection.
It reminds you of just how
surprising life can be.
You can come back from anything,
if you have enough love and
support around you.
In the face of grief, the only
way that we go on is hope.
♪♪